[Música]
y llegamos a la ciudad de jerusalén ahí
está nuestro corresponsal federico cue
barberena vamos a revisar entonces las
conclusiones de la primera parte de la
gira del presidente de eeuu joe biden
que concluyó en israel en este momento
fue de los saludo muy buena tarde le
pregunta entonces las conclusiones del
encuentro entre el presidente de bailén
y su homólogo israelí yair lapid en uno
de los temas más espinosos entre ambos
el acuerdo nuclear con irán
sí así es
raúl irán ocupó prácticamente el centro
de estas reuniones que mantuvieron yair
lapid y joe biden aquí en el hotel
waldorf astoria de jerusalén en el tema
irán bailén ratificó su postura de que
la diplomacia y el acuerdo nuclear
firmado en 2015 son la mejor manera de
evitar que irán desarrolle un arma
nuclear sobre esto dijo que irán a ya
saben los planteos de eeuu y que depende
de teherán decidir si se vuelve a
integrar por completo a este acuerdo
nuclear dijo que no hay un un decline
para esperar la respuesta de irán pero
que no van a esperar toda la vida y que
al margen de lo que ocurra con el
acuerdo eeuu está comprometido con no
permitir que irán desarrolle armas
nucleares del lado israelí hay una
pequeña diferencia en una diferencia en
el acercamiento a esta cuestión iraní
israel no cree
acuerdo nuclear con una solución y si
una solución más por la fuerza lápiz de
diseño señaló claramente que a veces
para llegar a la base se necesita el uso
de la fuerza y que irán debe creer que
existe una amenaza militar creíble es si
avanza con su programa nuclear pese a
que las potencias internacionales con
eeuu a la cabeza están haciendo lo
posible para que no lo haga en esta
pequeña diferencia fue la que plantearon
más allá de que el objetivo final es que
irán no avance con su programa de armas
nucleares pequeña injerencia un tono un
poco amenazante no fue pero el otro tema
que también divide es la solución de dos
estados para el conflicto entre
israelíes y palestinos que dijeron al
respecto
fue muy breve la referencia
principalmente del lado de hecho guaita
en quien señaló que la solución de dos
estados es la remanida fórmula que suele
evocar se para hablar de un estado
israelí y un estado palestino que logren
convivir en paz e igualdad según las
palabras de maiden es el objetivo final
para resolver este conflicto de décadas
entre palestinos e israelíes está claro
que no es una solución que a corto plazo
pueda llevarse a cabo como bien admitido
en la jornada de ayer y dijo que para
que esto ocurra se necesita un estado de
israel que tenga seguridad a largo plazo
no son palabras que seguramente vayan a
generar demasiado entusiasmo entre los
palestinos que ya son bastante
escépticos de la cee de que puede llegar
a dejarles esta visita de bailén que
tendrá su capítulo en los territorios
palestinos en mañana por la mañana
cuando se traslade primero a jerusalén
este para visitar un hospital y se
espera que anuncie un aumento en la
ayuda a los hospitales de jerusalén este
y luego tendrá esa reunión en belene con
el presidente de la autoridad palestina
donde se esperan algunos anuncios
es el posible compromiso de israel para
incorporar la tecnología 4g a los
territorios palestinos algo que se viene
prometiendo hace bastante tiempo y no ha
ocurrido luego de eso llegará el momento
entonces de dirigirse a arabia saudita
para el cierre de su primera gira por
medio oriente como presidente